RICK: When Reagan was
a conservative icon
Eisenhower was the person
who contained the divas,
and that includes people
like Patton, who didn't
want to listen to anyone.
RICK: Your hat has
seen better days.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I have here a campaign
hat from the 1960
Democratic Convention, and
a campaign poster from 1960
from Kennedy's campaign.
This was kind of
the standard poster
that Kennedy put out in his
presidential bid in 1960.
He was the first
candidate for president
ever to really
embrace television.
Do you remember this campaign?
I can remember little
bits about it, son.
I was in the
military at the time.
Kennedy was a Navy man.
RICK: That's right.
And that's how
come I voted for him.
RICK: Your hat has
seen better days.
The problem is, is they printed
this on really cheap paper.
It was never meant to last.
So we have this thing
right here literally--
Deteriorating in
front of our eyes.
RICK: I mean, the poster
is in pretty good shape.
One little tear, which is pretty
common for election posters
because people didn't take
care of them back then.
How much do you want for these?
Well, the poster I'd
like $250 and the hat $600.
Woo.
That's a lot of money.
So what do you think, Rick?
I'm thinking $200 for
the whole kit and caboodle.
I was thinking $250.
That was what I was
thinking, dammit.
Could you go up to $400?
I'll go $250.
That's what I can go.
All right.
OK, all right, it's a deal.
Thank you, sir.
COREY: Earlier a guy
brought in Ronald Reagan's
high school yearbook,
along with a letter
signed by Ronald Reagan.
It looks right, but
you never really know.
So I called my buddy, Drew,
to come down and take a look.
DREW: Ronald Reagan was
a conservative icon.
Like most presidents,
he's highly forged.
The value of it
is pretty strong.
So you always have to take
a look at all the details
and make sure it's authentic.
Well, one major thing that we're
always going to be looking for
is the couple r's
always supposed
to be larger in the first
name than in the last name.
I need to see that the
d is tilted back a bit,
because that's a style
that he would always do.
Very interesting.
T bars are at the top.
OK.
If we take all the evidence
together in its totality,
this is beautiful.
It's 100% authentic.
Great.
So what do you
think it's worth?
I would say all together,
the value of both the book
and the letter, if you framed it
up nice, retail $2,500, $3,000.
- Really?
- Yeah, how about that?
- Great.
- It looks like he scored.
All right, so what do
you think, Big Hoss?
Thinking around $1,800.
I'm thinking--
I mean, he said $25 to three
grand, so how about $2,500?
I would offer you
that, man, but I'm
going to have to frame it
and this is all going to have
to go together in one piece.
And it's going to
have to be in a way
that I can present it
and sell it to somebody.
$2,100.
I'll give you two grand
if it helps you out.
[SLOW GUITAR MUSIC]
All right.
COREY: Deal.
RICK: Earlier a guy came in
with a World War II book,
he says is signed by
Dwight D. Eisenhower.
Even if the signature is legit,
I have no way to price it.
So I called in my friend,
Rebecca, to help me out.
"Crusade in
Europe," this is all
about World War II,
specifically the European front.
Eisenhower was involved in this
from pretty much the beginning.
He was the person who
contained the divas,
and that includes people
like Patton, who didn't
want to listen to anyone.
[LAUGHTER]
Or General Montgomery,
who was the same way
on the British side.
I have the same book in
the signed limited edition.
RICK: OK.
REBECCA: What we're going to do
is look at the two signatures.
One thing that we
have to worry about
is that Eisenhower
actually had an autopen.
So there is the possibility
in this time period
that he could actually have
the autopen sign for him.
The nice thing about
this, though, is you have
this full inscription here.
And since you've got
a uniformity of ink
with the inscription
and the signature,
we know it's not autopen.
It's real.
RICK: Sweet.
Oh, that's great.
Awesome.
RICK: So what's it worth?
Without the jacket,
this book is worth $1,500.
If it had a dust
jacket, it needs
to retain the dust jacket.
If it was an original binding,
it should stay in that binding.
You're losing a huge
part of its value.
How much you want for it now?
She said $1,500, I'm
thinking and around $1,000.
That gives you a little room.
I'm thinking more like $800.
How about the
difference, $900?
We're still talking about
a lot of money for a book.
But it's an Eisenhower book.
$850.
No, I've got to stay with
nine, it's really unique.
You know what?
I'll go the nine.
- All right, we got a deal.
- All right.
- Thanks.
I'll meet you right up front.